>> ♪ ♪
>> WE ARE WILLING TO CONTINUE
NEGOTIATIONS.
ON THE OTHER HAND THE PRESIDENT
IS PREPARED TO DEFEND OUR
CENTER.
>> WE ALREADY LOST THE TRADE
WAR.
WE DON'T HAVE A TRADE WAR.
>> WE DON'T WANT TO FIGHT.
BUT WE ARE NOT AFRAID TO FIGHT A
TRADE WAR.
CHINA WILL FIGHT BACK FOR SURE.
CHINA WILL RESPOND IN A NEW AND
COMPREHENSIVE WAY.
>> WE ARE FOCUSSED ON THE
LONG-TERM ECONOMIC PRINCIPLES.
THE TARIFFS WITH CHINA HAVE NOT
BEEN IMPLEMENTED AND ARE MONTHS
AWAY.
>> WE MAY TAKE A HIT.
BUT WE WILL BE MUCH STRONGER FOR
IT.
>> Bret: WHAT WILL HAPPEN WHEN
THE NEW TARIFFS ARE PUT IN PLACE
AND CHINA RETALIATES?
THE DOW SHAKY ON THIS QUESTION
TODAY.
760 AND GOT SOME BACK AT THE END
OF THE TRADING DAY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN OPEN
ABOUT THIS.
HE'S BEEN TWEETING ABOUT IT.
WE PAY ATTENTION TO HIS TWEETS.
THIS IS A RE-TWEET OF HIS OWN
TWEET.
WE DO PAY SPECIAL ATTENTION TO
THIS ONE.
WE ARE NOT IN A TRADE WAR WITH
CHINA.
THAT WAR WAS LOST MANY YEARS AGO
BY THE FOOLISH OR INCOMPETENT
PEOPLE WHO REPRESENTED THE U.S.
WE HAVE A TRADE DEFICIT OF $500
BILLION A YEAR.
WE CAN'T LET THIS CONTINUE.
DOUBLE TWEETED THAT ONE.
OUR PANEL.
JONAH GOLDBERG FROM THE NATIONAL
REVIEW.
CHARLES OPINION WRITER FOR THE
"WASHINGTON POST" AND CHARLES
HURT FROM THE WASHINGTON TIMES.
CHARLIE, THOUGHTS WHERE THIS IS
HEADED AND A COLLISION COURSE WE
ARE LOOKING AT?
>> IT'S NOT SOMETHING WE HAVE
SEEN AROUND WASHINGTON FOR A
LONG TIME.
BUT, THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT
ABOUT THIS.
IF YOU LOOK BACK AT THE PAST 20
TO 30 YEARS, WE HAVE BEEN IN A
WAR WITH CHINA OVER ECONOMIES.
WHETHER IT'S TEXTILES OR
FURNITURE.
THEY STEAL OUR INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY AND OUR DESIGNS.
THEY HAVE BEEN EATING OUR LUNCH
FOR A LONG TIME.
IT'S SOMETHING IN POLITICIANS IN
BOTH PARTIES PAID LIP SERVICE TO
AND CAMPAIGNED ON.
THIS IS A GUY.
WE CAN DEBATE WHETHER THIS IS
THE RIGHT WAY TO DO.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT HE WON
THE ELECTION ON.
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> THEY ARE PROSPERITY KILLERS.
THEY ALWAYS HAVE BEEN.
IF YOU OPEN MARKETS AND CLEARLY
FOLLOW THE LAWS WITH RESPECT TO
TECHNOLOGY.
THIS WILL BE GOOD FOR EVERYBODY.
MY POINT IS, TARIFFS ENTER THE
PICTURE.
NEGOTIATIONS ENTER THE PICTURE.
YOU FOLLOW?
WHEN YOU JUST HAVE TO WALK
THROUGH THIS.
PROCESS AND WE WILL SEE
HOPEFULLY THIS WILL HAVE A VERY
HAPPY ENDING.
>> THIS IS A NEGOTIATION.
SAYING IT'S NOT A DONE DEAL YET.
THIS IS PART OF THE NEGOTIATION.
>> WELL, THE LINE OF AMERICAN
INDUSTRY ITSELF.
THE HIGH-TECH INDUSTRIES WHO ARE
VERY ANNOYED WITH CHINA.
THEY ARE GETTING HURT BY CHINA.
THEY FEAR A TOTAL BLOW UP.
WHAT THEY ARE ASKING OF THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS TO TREAT
THE END GAME WHERE THE GOAL IS
TO BRING CHINA BACK INTO THE WTO
COMPLIANCE.
NOT WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAYS TO
GET CHINA TO DECREASE ITS
DEFICIT IN THE UNITED
EKE
EK
WILL THE PRESIDENT ACCEPT WHAT
CHINA SEEMS TO BE PREPARED TO
OFFER.
MAYBE SOMEONE TRYING TO CALL OFF
THE TARIFFS.
OR WANT SOMETHING MORE.
>>
>> THEY ARE SO CONFUSED.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
I AM NOT SURE -- AMERICAN
BUSINESS NEED TO BE SCOLDED.
THEY COMPLAIN ABOUT IT BUT GO
ANNOUNCING OF THESE TERRORISTS
IS KIND OF LIKE THE SAYING AND
THE USUAL SUSPECTS WHERE HE
SUPPOSED TO KILL HIS OWN FAMILY
BEFORE HE EVEN TRIES TO
NEGOTIATE.
WE COULD HAVE GONE TO THE WTO A
YEAR AND A HALF AGO AND FILED A
COMPLAINT AGAINST A CHINA THAT
WE ARE REALLY AGGRESSIVE AND THE
FACT IS WE ARE NOT ALL THAT
COMPLIANT WITH THE WTO EITHER,
BUT CHINA HAS A MUCH DEEPER
INTEREST IN STAYING IN GOOD
GRACES AND THEY TEND TO ACTUALLY
COMPLY WITH THAT STUFF.
INSTEAD WE'VE GONE STRAIGHT TO
THE TRADE WERE PART WITHOUT
ACTUALLY WORKING ON THIS.
I LOVE LARRY KUDLOW, I'VE KNOWN
HIM FOR 20 YEARS, BUT HE'S IN
THE POSITION OF TRYING TO MAKE
THIS A RATIONAL THING ABOUT
NEGOTIATIONS, ABOUT INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY THEFT, BUT DONALD TRUMP
HAS, FOR 30 YEARS IS THAT HE
CARES ABOUT THE BILATERAL TRADE
STUFF.
HE HAS A DIFFERENT ECONOMIC VIEW
OF THIS STUFF.
>> Bret: IF HE SHAKES UP THE
POT LIKE HE DID ON NORTH KOREA,
IS THAT A BAD THING?
>> IT COULD BE A BAD THING OR
CAN BE A TERRIBLE THING.
>> Bret: LET'S TURN TO RUSSIA.
SPEAK OF THE HAS A SANCTIONED 17
TOP GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS AND
ALLIES OF RUSSIAN
PRESIDENT LEONARD PUT IN.
>> WHAT WE ALL WANT AT THE END'S
GOOD RELATIONSHIP WITH RUSSIA TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE A STABILIZED
REGION, BUT THAT OF COURSE WOULD
INCLUDE THAT RUSSIA DOES NOT
MOVE FORWARD WITH BAD BEHAVIOR.
>> WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE
WORKING FORWARD WITH WHAT WE CAN
TO HAVE THAT MEETING AND HAVE A
MEETING WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN AT
SOME POINT.
>> Bret: THE RUSSIAN EMBASSY
PUTTING OUT A STATEMENT IN
REACTION TO THE NEW SANCTIONS.
THE SANCTIONS COVER CAPTAINS OF
RUSSIAN BUSINESS WHO REFUSED TO
PLAY TO WASHINGTON SCENARIO.
WASHINGTON MADE YET ANOTHER
ERRONEOUS STEP TWO IMPAIR
INTEGRATION PROCESSES IN THE
GLOBAL ECONOMY.
THAT'S A WORDY STATEMENT FROM
THE RUSSIAN EMBASSY, BUT BOTTOM
LINE FOR ALL THE TALK, THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS PRETTY TOUGH
ON RATIONALE.
>> IT'S KIND OF UNFORTUNATE THAT
IT'S TAKEN THIS LONG, BUT A BIG
REASON FOR THAT IS IT'S SO EARLY
ON, THIS WHOLE ISSUE ABOUT
RUSSIAN MEDDLING IN THE ELECTION
BECAME SO HIGHLY POLITICIZED AND
IT TURNED INTO A PARTISAN THING
WHERE IT REALLY SHOULDN'T HAVE
BEEN NEARLY AS PARTISAN AS IT
IS.
QUITE FRANKLY, I THINK THE LIES
THAT HAVE TURNED THIS RUSSIA
THING ANYWAY THAT THEY CAN SMEAR
DONALD TRUMP.
>> WHAT STRIKES ME ABOUT THIS IS
THE SWEEPING NATURE, THE TOUGH
NATURE OF THE CONDEMNATION OF
RUSSIAN BEHAVIOR.
THEY ARE SPECIFYING IT'S BECAUSE
OF LONDON OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT,
IT'S BECAUSE RUSSIA IS GENERALLY
CREATING MISCHIEF IN THE WORLD